Greece doesn't have banks right now or
at least the banks aren't open what's
happening there can it happen here or
what should Americans be scared about or
interested in
well absolutely can happen here in fact
it's happening here in a way in Puerto
Rico which is still here right it's part
of the United States it's not a state
but it's a territory Porto Ricans are
American citizens but what's happening
in Greece and what's happening in Puerto
Rico is going to happen in the United
States it's all about politicians who
have promised more than their tax payers
can deliver and they have all these
obligations whether it's to creditors or
to voters in in the form of pensions
that have been promised right and Greece
is broke they can't they can't pay Berto
Rico the Governor of Puerto Rico just
admitted that Puerto Rico cannot pay its
bills which is rare that a politician
will be honest about the inability to
pay bills because the reality is we're
in worse shape then Puerto Rico the
debt-to-gdp there is only about 70% here
it's over a hundred percent and that's
just the tip of the iceberg that's just
the the actual funded debt the Treasury
obligations that are outstanding but the
reason that Puerto Rico is having to
face the music whereas we're still you
know dancing to it in the United States
is because interest rates have risen in
Puerto Rico and it's the higher rates
that create the problem that's what
happened in Greece when interest rates
at Greece were still at record lows
the politicians could keep on borrowing
and keep on pretending that they can pay
it back but once the Greek creditors
began to question the solvency of Greece
they demanded higher interest rates
that's when greets became insolvent so
the same situation is going to take
place in the United States the only
reason that we can pretend that we're
solvent is because interest rates are at
zero right the Fed has kept them at zero
for seven years long term Treasuries the
10-year Treasury yields about two
percent and under that scenario the
enormity of our debt is manageable at
least the interest payments we can't
possibly pay back the principal but we
can at least make those minimum interest
payments but the minute our creditors
figure out that we're in the same
position as Greece or Puerto Rico
they're going to demand higher rate of
interest from us and we can't
hey either Greece is going to have to
basically default you think of course
see Greece can't print euros so if they
they have to default America can print
dollar so we don't have to default in
you know in actuality where we just not
don't pay but what we can do is print
money and pay people with worthless
dollars but that's the same result
because our creditors don't get any
purchasing power and I would argue that
defaulting through inflation which is
what it is when the central bank ends up
monetizing the debt because the
taxpayers you know can't pay it I think
that's actually more damaging to the
economy and to our creditors than a
legitimate restructuring where you
acknowledge your problem and then the
creditors agree to accept less than full
face value and you also have reductions
in government spending
you tell pensioners or people who have
been promised various benefits from
government that they can't get what
they've been promised they're gonna have
to get something less because if you pay
everybody off by printing money
the real loss in purchasing power is
even greater sure as always thank you
very much Peter Schiff the reason TV I'm
Matt Welch